so william router has been declared the
winner of kenya's presidential election
he received just over fifty percent of
the vote less than
two percent ahead of his rival and
former prime minister rylo odinga ruto
is promising radical economic reform
gender equity and he's also calling for
unity
i am a very proud kenyan this evening
that the people of kenya have raised
the bar on us
who are seeking leadership in our
country
not to sell our ethnicities but to sell
our programs
our manifestos
our agenda and our plan
but there is controversy around his win
shortly before the result was announced
scuffles broke out at the national
tallying center in nairobi the election
commission's deputy chairman and three
other commissioners rejected the results
raising questions about the integrity of
the vote well rylo odinga supporters
they reacted angrily in his stronghold
of kusumu they believe the election was
stolen please fire tear gas to break up
the demonstration
marco webb is live for us in nairobi so
malcolm we waited and we waited and we
waited and all of a sudden there was
chaos in the counting center and then
ruto was declared winner
and absent throughout that process was
ryder odinga uh himself william ruta
arrived here uh he was attending uh the
the announcement of these results
sadinga was nowhere to be seen uh his
supporters now
are angry not just in kasumu that city
in western kenya that you mentioned but
also here in nairobi
in kibera and mathari two of the largest
slums
where odinga enjoys
quite a lot of strong support
but shortly before those results were
announced ryder rodinger's chief agent
uh marched out of the tally center here
and spoke to the press let's hear what
he had to say
we have
intelligence
that their system
was penetrated
and hacked
and that some of the ibc officials
actually committed
electoral offenses
and
some of them ought to have been arrested
if they are not arrested
well it looks like there's going to be
serious objections what's the process
for any kind of dispute in this
situation
well according to the constitution
a complainant has seven days after the
announcement of the results to submit a
petition uh to the courts uh this is
exactly what happened five years ago
following the last election ryla
redinger at that time was leading the
opposition
his coalition submitted a petition and
the supreme court ruled that the
election uh had in fact had major
irregularities it annulled the result
and ordered a rerun uh that took place a
couple of months later and ryler's
coalition didn't compete in it because
they said those irregularities uh were
never fixed so now uh the railroading is
a zimea coalition's got seven days to
file a petition and if it does so
then the supreme court has 14 days to
reply so we'd find out at that stage in
the case that there is a a court hearing
if these results are indeed going to be
upheld or not if william roto is going
to be the next president of kenya or if
like last time
the supreme court will order a re-run
laura malcolm thanks for that
malcolm webb there nairobi we talked
about those protests in kazumu harry
matassa was there
disbelief quickly turned into anger this
is ryla odinga stronghold people were
expecting him to win when they heard the
results that he didn't they were angry
they were saying things like the people
in nairobi at the tele center are
thieves they want to know what happened
to their vote they're telling raila
odinga not to accept the results they're
busy picking up sticks and stones their
way of saying that they plan to be out
here as long as possible until they get
surmounted until they hear from their
leader ryla odinga this part of kenya
western kenya these people feel they've
been marginalized for years they were
hoping that if odinga had won maybe
their own man could maybe look after
their needs but now they say what is
going to happen now their candidate
according to natural commission has lost
their selection they're angry they're
frustrated and they want to know what
the way forward is going to be for ryla
odinga
harry matassa reporting there well ruto
faces major challenges as he takes over
the presidency among them rising
inflation unemployment and record high
levels of public debt kenya was
particularly hard hit by the pandemic
because tourists were unable to visit
both william reuter and his defeated
opponent rylo dinger promised to tackle
widespread corruption but critics say
their roles in previous scandal hit
governments cast doubt on those pledges
on top of that a prolonged drought has
increased the risk of people going
hungry some of the poorest in kenya can
only afford one meal a day
so let's bring in nagala tromme he's a
senior analyst at zahan research that's
a think tank that works on peace and
security issues in the horn of africa
joins us now from nairobi nagala welcome
to the show
what is your sense before we get into
the challenges ahead what is your sense
of what might happen next if a dinger
refuses to accept the result
um well so kreila odinga has actually
not at at the time speaking has not
issued any statement but it is quite
likely that he will
he's actually preparing to go to the
supreme court to challenge the results
of this election
we saw that a few minutes before the
results were announced uh his party
agent had refused to sign the the the
the the required forms um so therefore
what we're really expecting is is that
the the losing candidate in this case
railroading will be will be heading to
court pretty soon to challenge the
election
of course everybody fears the violence
that we've seen at previous elections
and that's that's the situation
everybody wants to avoid
yes um um
i've just been uh uh before this
interview just i just uh took a stroll
of uh of of fiber slums which is um
known in previous elections as as one of
the hot spots of election values but
also the sort of a base support base for
for for for for
um
the situation um as far as i could tell
did not seem as tense of course anything
can change especially depending on what
raila odinga does next
um
but i'm still confident that the kind of
levels of violence we've seen in
previous elections especially in 2007
will not be repeated this time around
there will be scuffles there will be
protests um um but also the security
agencies i'm sure are quite prepared to
to respond and to restore order the only
issue of course or concern
is is when you start you know getting
reports of of of killings and and and
and due force
uh on the part of the security agencies
indeed well assuming reuter holds on to
his win to what degree do you think he's
equipped to tackle the challenges
um it will all boil down to um the
issues that
that the
the petitioner presents to the court um
if there were problems with the election
as they have put out
it is yet not very clear what exactly
the problems were um it is also very
instructive to to to note
that that uh four of the of the seven
commissioners of the electoral
commission have decided to
disassociate themselves
from the from the from the from the
announcement of of these results and and
that in itself is pretty key but again
like i said we also do not know exactly
why they've decided to do that and i
think all these matters will then become
a subject of the
of the you know very likely
presidential petition
it was an incredibly close run thing
whatever happens
probably not helped by a lower voter
turnout compared to the last election
um yes uh the you know the voter turnout
is about 10 percent less than 2017
um
which wasn't expected but given what has
happened in the last five years you know
a rising cost of living people growing
more apathetic um
you know people had had come out of a
sort of post-pandemic
situation
that would explain uh the law of water
turnout but also the sort of shifting
political alliances as well you know um
um i think it's a it's an indication
that kenyans uh also becoming a little
bit
tired of of this sort of constantly
changing political political dynamics uh
in the country and it will also partly i
think explain
why in these elections actually there
might be lower levels of violence
because for the last one week what most
people are asking uh uh is is for this
process to be concluded so that they can
go back to their regular lives this is
something important to note as well
all right well we'll see how the coming
days pan out and garlic jeremy
appreciate that thanks a lot
thank you very much